public sénat ravi de vous retrouver sur
public sénat dans un instant vous allez
pouvoir suivre la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi de bioéthique à mes côtés
pour en parler alain milon sénateur ump
du vaucluse et rapporteur de ce texte
ici au sénat bonjour bonjour alors il ya
de nombreuses modifications apportées
par les sénateurs à ce texte notamment
en ce qui concerne l'autorisation de la
recherche sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires comment explique-t-on les
réticences de la france et du coup son
retard en la matière je pense qu'on n'y
a pas véritablement de réticences de la
france
la france a interdit les recherches sur
l'embryon et sur les souches sur les
cellules souches embryonnaires pardon
mais elle les autorise à titre
exceptionnel qui veut dire donc qu'elle
les autorise le problème c'est que tous
les chercheurs ne voient pas leurs
recherches pérenniser du fait qu'il ya
une interdiction générale et l'image que
l'on donne à l'étranger et pas une bonne
image puisqu'en fait image on donne
c'est une image d'interdiction donc la
commission des affaires sociales à
mesure où c'est autorisé préfère dire
que c'est autorisé
d'une manière générale avec évidemment
une réglementation importante sur le
sujet ce qui me semble logique aussi en
espérant que ce texte qui est passé
difficilement commission des affaires
sociales puissent passer en assemblée
c'est que c'est un débat qui est
extrêmement clivant cela va au delà
litres de clivage traditionnel droite
gauche
la commission des affaires sociales du
sénat s'est prononcé en faveur de la
levée de l'anonymat pour les donneurs de
gamètes
contrairement à la commission des lois
comment le sénat va agir sur ce sujet
alors là la nouvelle
m s'est passé d'une manière plus large
au niveau de la commission des affaires
sociales le problème c'est aussi en
séance va voir comment ça se passe là il
y à un accord assez général plutôt du
côté de l'ump que du côté de la gauche
sur le sujet pour la levée d'anonymat
pour des raisons qui semble évidente
puisque c'est le respect de la signature
des droits de l'enfant que la france a
signé cette charte qui dit que tout
enfant a droit à l'accès à ses origines
en conséquence même un enfant qui est né
pardon diamètre doit avoir les mêmes
droits que les autres
dans ce texte sur la bioéthique il ya
donc un long chapitre consacré à la mp
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
on sait que vous même vous aviez déposé
une proposition de loi visant à
légaliser la gpa la gestation pour
autrui
on vient d'apprendre justement que le
couple mennesson qui donc demandé
l'inscription à l'état civil français
pour ses jumelles nées d'une mère
porteuse à l'étranger bien la cour de
cassation a refusé l'inscription à
l'état civil est ce que cette décision
va changer le cours de la discussion au
sénat
mais je ne pense pas non je pense que la
gestation pour autrui
certains disent les mères porteuses
justement pour éviter qu'on en parle
la gestation pour autrui c'est quelque
chose qui existe pratiquement d'une
manière libre sur internet pour les gens
quels qu'ils soient qui ont les moyens
de le faire et les enfants qui naissent
de ces mères porteuses
finalement en arrivant en france n'ont
pas le droit à leur filiation
ce qui fait qu'ils sont un petit peu
apatrides en tout cas si le père décédé
il se retrouver dans une situation assez
complexe puisqu'il n'ont pas le droit
d'avoir leur mère comme maire donc le
sujet va rebondir
et si on interdit à ses enfants d'être
reconnus et si on interdit la gpa en
france il faut interdire aux français
d'aller à l'étranger est en tout cas
mettre ça au même niveau qu'un crime du
type de la pédophilie
auquel cas on se retrouvait dans une
situation qui serait conforme au souhait
de certains je pense que on est devant
un fait important la gpa
qu'on le veuille ou non qu'on soit
choqué ou non et si on ne fait pas
quelque chose pour lutter contre la
marchandisation du corps humain pour
faire en sorte que ça se passe dans des
conditions sanitaires satisfaisantes
on n'avancera pas véritablement sur le
sujet merci alain milon d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je vous laisse tout de
suite regagné à l'hémicycle du sénat
à suivre donc l'examen du projet de loi
de bioéthique très bonne science à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale relatif à la
bioéthique dans la discussion des
articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 88 rectifié tendance a inséré un
article additionnel après l'article 5
quatre amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement 88 rectifier et présentée
par monsieur fisher oui monsieur le
président madame la ministre
comme vous le savez les dons d'organes
sont régis actuellement par trois grands
principes la gratuité l'anonymat elle
consentement en l'état actuel du droit
le consentement au don sur une personne
décédée
c'est à dire au prélèvement est présumé
chaque personne décédée est en quelque
sorte un donneur potentiel
or il ne s'agit là et les équipes le
voit au quotidien que d'une hypothèse
tout théorique puisque dans les faits et
dans la loi
celle ci peut être renversé à deux
occasions
tout d'abord si le défunt a de son
vivant fait connaître son refus d'un
prélèvement sur son corps après la mort
mais également si un proche du défunt
témoignent du refus de ce dernier
d'autoriser les prélèvements d'organes
si le cadre législatif actuel qui date
tout de même de 1976 a été pertinent de
nombreuses années notamment parce que
les données scientifiques d'alors ne
permettait pas de réaliser
autant de transplantation que cela est
possible aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il
faut imaginer à côté de ce qui existe
aujourd'hui un nouvel outil juridique
pour nous et c'est le sens de cet
amendement il est impératif si l'on veut
réduire la pénurie de dons d'organes que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui de prévoir
dans la loi un registre positif
c'est-à-dire enregistre dans lequel les
personnes pourraient préciser de leur
vivant qu'elle souhaite donner leurs
organes
cette proposition portée par ailleurs
par toutes les associations qui
promeuvent le don de vie constitue pour
nous un élément important au delà des
évolutions législatif ainsi que des
conséquences positives sur le nombre de
prélèvements
elle est la reconnaissance réelle du
principe d'autonomie de la décision
si la loi garantit le respect des
volontés exprimées par ceux qui refusent
de donner leurs organes
alors par parallélisme et j'ai envie de
dire par respect pour le geste altruiste
de ceux qui veulent donner leurs organes
la loi doit garantir que cette démarche
sera pleinement respectée
tel est le sens de cet amendement par
ailleurs et pour que les choses soient
claires il ne s'agit pas de revenir sur
la notion de présomption du de dons ce
que nous proposons c'est un système
parallèle à celui ci soit la personne
décédée a fait connaître de son vivant
c'est et volonté en matière de
prélèvements que ce soit le don ou le
refus de don est alors les équipes
médicales doivent respecter cette
décision sans avoir à rechercher une
quelconque opposition soit elle ne l'a
pas fait et l'actuel alinéa 3 de
l'article l
12 132-1 du code de la santé publique
s'applique et le médecin qui n'a pas
directement connaissance de la volonté
du défunt devra toujours et c'est ce qui
fait ses forces et de recueillir auprès
des proches
l'opposition don d'organes
éventuellement exprimé de son vivant par
le défunt c'est à dire qu'est conservé
intact
le principe de présomption voilà
monsieur le président merci chers
collègues l'amendement 156e rectifier et
présenté par madame laborde
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est un amendement qui va dans le même
sens que celui que viennent de défendre
le président fischer est plutôt que
d'organiser donc le don d'organes sur la
base du volontariat
la france a mis en place la règle du
consentement présumé au prélèvement de
dons d'organes
toute personne est donc considéré comme
consentantes au don de ses organes
si elle n'a pas manifesté d'opposition
de son vivant et toute personne qui
s'oppose à de tels prélèvements peut
s'inscrire sur le registre national des
refus au prélèvement
si le médecin n'a pas directement
connaissance de la volonté du défunt
il doit s'efforcer de recueillir auprès
des proches
l'opposition éventuellement exprimé de
son vivant
or dans la plupart des cas les proches
ignorent la volonté du défunt la
décision repose donc sur la famille qui
se trouve confronté à un choix difficile
dans un moment très douloureux
c'est la raison pour laquelle elle
refuse dans plus de 30 % des cas et bien
que la loi présume du consentement du
défunt en l'absence de signes clairs
d'opposition les médecins ne vont jamais
à l'encontre de la décision prise par
les proches de ce fait le nombre de
transplantations régressent et le nombre
de malades en attente de greffe ne cesse
de croître
par ailleurs le tourisme de la
transplantation la commercialisation et
le trafic des organes se développe
dangereusement sur internet
cet amendement ne remet en cause
aucunement le consentement présumé
il propose de mettre en place
parallèlement au registre national des
refus au prélèvement un registre
national de consentement au don
d'organes tel qu'il existe dans d'autres
pays européens
l'existence d'un tel registre apportera
une solution à ceux qui ne veulent ou ne
peuvent pas en parler à leurs proches et
qui craignent que leur volonté ne soit
pas respecté elle permettrait de
connaître précisément la position du
défunt
cela faciliterait le rôle des personnels
médicaux et de soulager les proches dans
un moment aussi douloureux
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
l'amendement 156 rectifiée présentée par
monsieur sueur merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
cet amendement va exactement dans le
même sens de celui que que ceux qui
viennent d'être présentés par monsieur
fisher madame laborde en matière de don
post mortem d'organes et de tissus
humains
vous savez tous que la loi repose sur le
principe du consentement présumé la loi
du 29 juillet 1994 a instauré un
registre des refus monsieur le président
donc si un citoyen refuse que l'on
puisse utiliser ses organes après sa
mort il peut tout à fait déclaré cela
sur un registre
or ce qui est incompréhensible c'est que
lorsque un citoyen ou une citoyenne veut
répondre positivement à l'appel des
médecins
je rappelle que selon le rapport annuel
de la chance de la biomédecine environ
800 à 850 malades en attente d'une
greffe sont décédés faute d'un greffon
disponibles donc les médecins nous ont
écrit et les associations qui regroupent
les partisans du don d'organes nous ont
écrit pour nous dire
il existe la possibilité de sauver des
vies il y a aujourd'hui des personnes
qui meurent faute d'un greffon
disponible c'est la réalité
moi j'ai écouté les médecins hors la loi
aujourd'hui elle permet de dire qu'on
n'est pas d'accord elle ne peut
mais pas de dire qu'on est d'accord donc
nous demandons simplement de manière à
sauver des vies
j'insiste là dessus que l'on puisse
créer un registre positif où tous les
citoyens qui accepte que une fois qu'ils
seront morts il faut des conditions
particulières et si la médecine juge que
les conditions sont remplies et bien
leurs organes puissent être donné pour
sauver un frère ou une soeur en humanité
et donc monsieur le rapporteur
j'espère vraiment que vous allez
répondre favorablement à ce que nous
présentons avec mes collègues
j'ajoute pour finir monsieur le
président que le 29 décembre 2010 j'ai
déposé une proposition de loi signée par
un très grand nombre de nos collègues
allant dans ce sens puisque c'est
tellement évident que l'on m'a dit à
plusieurs reprises qu'il n'était pas
utile de l'inscrire à l'ordre du jour
puisque cela viendrait dans la loi
bioéthique que j'ai déposé le contenu de
cette proposition de loi et j'en termine
dans la loi dans le projet de loi de
simplification et d'amélioration de la
qualité du droit
et l'on m'a dit mais vous avez tout à
fait raison mais ce n'est pas le bon
endroit il faut en parler lors de la loi
de bioéthique
nous y sommes et vraiment je crois que
le sénat s'honorer et frais avancés d'un
grand pas s'il donnait aux françaises et
aux français la possibilité de déclarer
qu'ils sont favorables au don d'organes
merci chaque collègue l'amendement 89
rectifier et présenté par l'âme la barre
oui en complément de ces trois
amendements
nous proposons de modifier aussi
l'alinéa 3 de l'article l 12300 21-1 du
code de la santé
public cette année n'ya concerne la
possibilité donnée par la loi aux
proches du défunt de s'opposer aux
prélèvements dès lors que celui-ci
n'aurait pas fait connaître clairement
son opposition prélèvements sur le
registre national des refus prévu dans
ce même article
cette rédaction mes chers collègues est
surprenante tout d'abord il fait
référence à la notion de proches
celle ci est particulièrement floues et
l'on est en droit de se demander à quel
niveau de connaissances du défunt on est
on peut être qualifiée de proche
par ailleurs l'article prévoit je le
cite si le médecin n'a pas directement
connaissance de la volonté du défunt
il doit s'efforcer de recueillir auprès
des proches
l'opposition au don d'organes
éventuellement exprimé de son vivant par
le défunt
le recours à la ddt verbe éventuellement
et des plus surprenants c'est à dire que
si la personne décédée n'a jamais parlé
à son entourage de ses convictions en
matière de dons d'organes
il appartient il appartiendra aux
proches de décider à sa place sur le
fondement de leurs propres convictions
personnelles religieuses philosophiques
ou morale autant dire que dans ce cadre
la présomption n'est plus que théorique
notre amendement vise donc partiellement
à remédier à ces difficultés en limitant
aux parents d'enfants mineurs et à la
personne de confiance désignée de son
vivant par la personne décider des cds
la possibilité de s'opposer dans le
silence de celle ci à ce que soit
réalisé des prélèvements
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
avant de donner l'avis de la commission
vous relire ce que nous a dit madame
prada-bordenave sur le sujet la
directrice de l' agence de biomédecine
elle a dit s'en être la meilleure la
france est en bon rang en ce qui
concerne le don d'organes elle est
devancée par l'espagne et le portugal
mais nous savons que en espagne à des
compensations financières qui enregistre
pour ces deux pays trente donneurs pour
un million d'habitants et la france
enregistrent 24 d'honneur pour un
million d'habitants
grâce au plan ambitieux intitulé les 80
consistant à passer de 15 à 20 donneurs
par million d'habitants suivi du plan
greffe qui a obligé tous les
établissements de santé jusqu'aux
établissements d'hébergement personnes
âgées dépendantes à participer à
l'effort de dons sanguins un corner
notre pays a atteint de bons résultats
le désengagement des établissements de
santé depuis trois ou quatre ans pose en
difficulté la ministre de la santé nous
a demandé de réfléchir au lancement d'un
nouveau plan
nous lui remontant les éléments famars
l'allemagne et la grande bretagne ont un
système qui rend obligatoire
l'inscription sur un jeu registre et la
détention d'une carte de donneur pour
permettre les prélèvements d'organes
or ils ont des résultats moins
satisfaisant que les résultats français
entre 13 et 15 d'honneur pour un million
d'habitants et l'organisation mondiale
de la santé recommande l'adoption du
système français
il est loin il est de loin le plus
simple tout français est prisonnier est
présumé d'honneur après son heure
à partir de là évidemment vous
comprendrez les avis de la commission
alors pour l'amendement 88 rectifiée
présentée par monsieur fisher et le
groupe crc la possibilité de s'inscrire
sur un registre national des donneurs
n'a pas donné donc de grands résultats
dans les pays où il a été mis en place
comme le royaume-uni puisqu'ils sont à
15 et noah 24
il est à craindre que cette disposition
même si elle vient compléter la loi
caillavet et non se substituer à elle
n'entrave le système actuel de dont la
bm et les équipes de grève sont
majoritairement défavorables
une évolution de ce type c'est donc un
avis défavorable de la commission
même avis pour le moment ça 156 qui est
sensiblement identique à l'amendement
précédent pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 15 présentée par monsieur
sueur et membre du groupe socialiste et
donc un avis défavorable avec de
surcroît le fait que cet amendement met
fin au dispositif de dons sauf
opposition prévu par la loi caillavet
donc avis défavorable et puis pour
l'amendement 89 rectifier sept
amendements limitent l'obligation de
demander le consentement de la famille
au seul cas où le donneur potentiel est
mineure comme l'a expliqué la directrice
générale de la bm
cette demande de consentement de la
famille se pratiquent même dans les pays
où le consentement exprès est prévue il
paraît donc illusoire de vouloir
s'opposer au fait que l'équipe de grève
demande d'autorisation des proches c'est
un avis favorable
merci monsieur rapporteur madame le
ministre l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
le gouvernement est défavorable en fait
aux différents amendements qui sont
proposés pour la
la mise en place d'un registre de
consentement dont qui n'est pas
souhaitable pour des raisons
d'efficacité de santé publique
l'exemple d'autres pays européens qui
applique une réglementation de
consentement exprès montre d'une part
que peu de personnes font la démarche
d'inscrire leur volonté sur un support
écrit et d'autre part que les
prélèvements par le taux de prélèvement
par million d'habitants ils sont plus
faibles on habite beauty ainsi à une
moindre à une moindre disponibilité
d'organes par ailleurs une enquête fut
en 2006 indique 97% de la population
respecterait la décision du défunt si
celui ci lui en avait fait part de son
vivant merci madame la ministre
alors pour explication de vote sur le
82,8 rectifié ma la meilleure mange
lançant la position de notre groupe
qu'en fait elle storey afficher des
accords risque de revenir sur le
consentement présumé ce qu'ils doivent
faire l'objet d'un vrai débat est donc
notre groupe suivra donc la position de
la commission je ne sais pas si je donne
la vie sur le 89 tout de suite ou tout à
l'heure oui donné le 2 mai le je vous en
prie 189 supprimés au delà des arguments
qu'a donnée le rapporteur supprimer le
mot proches par le mot parent des
donneurs est de plus en plus de
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui sans lien
de famille
j'ai le souvenir par exemple d'avoir
travaillé sur un certain nombre de
documents
concert concert concernant le
consentement exprès et présumés il
n'était raconté l'histoire d'un sdf qui
s'appelait titi et dont la famille a
retrouvé
c'est le fait qu'ils étaient prélevées
très tardivement mais effectivement le
mot proches lui aurait permis de confier
ça à un proche temps d'un riverain par
exemple alors qu'il n'avait que s'il n'a
pas de famille aurait pas pu le faire et
donc je trouve que le mot proche est
tout à fait approprié par rapport aux
parents du donneur cher collègue
monsieur mason pour explications de vote
le président je suis pour ma part
modérément enfin je suis très prudent
face à la logique du consentement
présumé
parce que il ya aussi faut aussi
respecter les personnes humaines et donc
quand il n'y a pas d'avis bon je veux
bien qu'on présume consentement mais il
la meilleure des choses c'est de ces que
soient clarifiées et donc je pense que
les amendements 10 ans ont créé un
registre où les gens disent moi je suis
d'accord de données c'est très bien
d'ailleurs l'argument qui a été opposé
c'est ça ne donne pas de grands
résultats fin j'ai noté ce qui est ce qu
a dit je puisse tel ministre ou
rapporteurs ça ne donne pas de grands
résultats
mais le problème à mon avis c'est pas de
savoir si ça donne de grands résultats
ou pas grand résultat
c'est d'abord de respecter le souhait de
la personne qui est concerné parce qu'on
va quand même pas couper une personne en
quatre en dépit de ce qu'elle peut
souhaiter et c'est simplement pour sur
telle ou telle logique de présomptions
et donc moi je pense pour ma part qu'il
est extrêmement souhaitable d'avoir non
pas un deuxième registre avec les avis
positifs mais tout simplement un seul
registre où les gens disent bien où les
gens qui le souhaitent 10 moi je suis
pour donner mes organes ou
éventuellement moi je suis contre donner
mes organes et sur l'amendement 89
oui alors là je suis radicalement
hostile parce que dit on c'est la porte
ouverte à une logique totalitaire ou ou
disons à peine les gens sont morts
on commence on fait tout ce qu'on peut
pour ne pas respecter finalement ce
qu'ils souhaitent ou ou consulter le
moins de gens possible avec un certain
nombre de résultats qui sont pas
hautement souhaitable et moi j'attache
beaucoup d'importance à la au respect du
corps humain est le respect du corps
humain c'est aussi ça merci cher
collègue monsieur sueur pour explication
bottes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre madame lepage et monsieur
cazaux à weyer parlé avec beaucoup de
convictions et mes collègues monsieur
fisher et madame laborde aussi à
l'instant monsieur masson aussi suis-je
consterné monsieur le président je le
dis nettement par rapport à ce qui a été
déclaré à ce sujet par monsieur le
rapporteur et par madame la ministre
en effet monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez su faire preuve d'innovation dans
certains domaines
et alors là je ne vous retrouve pas
monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez d'abord dit quelque chose qui
n'est pas tout à fait exact vous avez
dire que le fait de rendre la
déclaration obligatoire n'était pas
positif mais nous ne proposons pas de
rendre la déclaration obligatoire
notre amendement dispose que le
consentement explicite de la personne un
tel prélèvement peut être enregistrés
donc vous êtes d'accord monsieur le
rapporteur que cet amendement platt que
cet argument la tombe
il tombe de fait nous pensons qu'il est
utile d'offrir à nos concitoyens la
faculté de déclarer qu'ils sont pour le
don d'organes après leur mort voilà
deuxièmement la réalité
actuelle c'est que si le défunt s'est
exprimé de son vivant auprès de ses
proches la famille peut témoigner
et dans ce cas il n'y a pas de
difficultés si au contraire le defy n'a
jamais abordé ce sujet ce qui est très
fréquent la famille est confrontée à une
décision d'une relative complexité
cette complexité d'ailleurs accentuée
par la contrainte du temps qui entraîne
une confrontation entre la famille et le
corps médical dès le constat du décès
alors même que le processus de gueye de
deuil n'est pas amorcée ce qui constitue
une source d'angoissé pour tous et
suscite des refus sur lesquelles
certaines familles souhaitent revenir
par la suite
malheureusement trop tard
actuellement même si le défunt et
consentants déclaré rien ne garantit le
respect de sa volonté
en effet aucune des cartes qui sont
envoyées par les associations n'ont de
valeur juridique vous le savez alors mes
chers collègues nous proposons
simplement que l'on est la faculté de
dire est que ce soit enregistré que l'on
est pour le don d'organes comme on a
aujourd'hui la faculté de dire et cela
est enregistrée prévue par la loi que
l'on est contre quels arguments
allez-vous nous opposer et j'ai été
étonné madame hermange de vous entendre
dire au nom de tout votre groupe unanime
que vous étiez contre mais vraiment mes
chers collègues vous mes chers collègues
vous êtes vraiment compte le fait que si
un citoyen veut déclarer je suis prêt à
donner mes organes après la mort pour
que cela puisse sauver une vie humaine
vous êtes d'accord pour dire qu'il ne
faut pas que ce soit possible que cette
faculté n'existe pas
je je reviens là dessus toutes les
associations nous ont parlé
les médecins ont parlé et vous avez lu
monsieur le rapporteur ce qu'a dit la
directrice de l' agence de l'ami de la
biomédecine
je rappelle qu'al agence de la
biomédecine dit que dans l'année 2008
entre 800 et 850 personnes malades sont
mortes faute d'un greffon disponibles eh
bien madame hermange je sais que vous
tenez beaucoup à la vie eh bien nous
tenons tous à la vie
et lorsque l'on peut faire en sorte
qu'en donnant ses organes
eh bien on sauve une vie humaine on
devrait tous être d'accord
alors nous ne ferons aucune obligation
nous instaurons la faculté pour chaque
être humain de dire je suis d'accord
pour qu'en donnant un de mes organes et
bien on sauver une vie humaine
donc nous sommes vraiment partisan de
cet amendement et j'espère avoir montré
que les arguments qui ont été opposés
par monsieur le rapporteur et madame la
ministre ne tiennent pas et j'espère
vraiment mes chers collègues que vous
voterez ces amendements
monsieur fisher monsieur le président je
crois qu'il faut être clair il ne s'agit
pas de remettre en cause le consentement
présumé
parce que certains dans leurs
interventions
eh bien nous accuse de vouloir remettre
ce consentement présumé de vouloir le
remettre en cause non il s'agit pas au
contraire nous souhaitons le respecter
profondément et nous avons déjà dit sur
les principes comment nous abordions ce
débat et on l'a montré toute la journée
d'hier mais de là à faire un pas et
notamment à ce que l'on puisse
enregistrer sur 1 re j 7 voulons
et de faire don d'un organe et bien il y
as peut-être de notre part à prendre en
compte cette possibilité et là vous vous
y refusé mais je dois dire et nous avons
tous ont eu à vivre des moments très
douloureux notamment lorsque un de nos
proches décède et bien que le moment du
décès parce que la plupart de nos
concitoyens morts dans les hôpitaux
publics
et on sait que le temps que va pouvoir
consacrer à la famille véritablement la
possibilité de pouvoir fournir à la
famille toutes les hypothèses de peu de
dons d'organes
et bien c'est un moment très court qui
est bien souvent est limitée par le
collaborateur du patron du service qui
est une discussion parfois entre deux
portes
on n'a pas la pièce dans les hôpitaux
publics où on n'a pas les locaux qui
permettent d'accueillir dignement les
familles pour parler de ces problèmes là
et je crois que c'était cette volonté
que nous souhaitions de traiter plus
humainement et bien ce cet instant très
dur pour les familles lorsque un de ses
proches s'en va et cette possibilité de
donner un organe est bien devrait être
pris plus en considération alors il ya
eu de très grands efforts qui ont été
faits dans les hôpitaux publics
mais on sait que les conditions de
travail que la réduction des moyens la
réduction des lits font que notamment la
nuit parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
mord la nuit et bien notamment la nuit
c'est très difficile de pouvoir
satisfaire
cette réalité est notamment de pouvoir
parler en toute connaissance de cause de
ce problème du don d'organes merci cher
collègue monsieur mirassou pour
explication de vote et si monsieur le
président madame lise mes chers
collègues
ces interventions courtes pour apporter
un soutien plus parfait possible à
l'amendement numéro 15 qui comme vient
de le dire à la fois entre collègues
fisher et sueur ne se substitue pas à
l'existant mais amène quelque chose de
supplémentaire à plus forte raison parce
que dans le cadre de l'enregistrement du
consentement du don ca obéira à quelque
chose qui fera largement appelle au
libre arbitre d'une manière réfléchie et
en amont si bien que les inconvénients
ou qu'elle vient faire allusion notre
collègue fischer pourront être en partie
éliminer cette formidable course
poursuite qui existe entre la recherche
de l'organe compliqué parfois par des
contradictions au sein d'une même
famille dans le cadre de ce qui existe
déjà
j'ajoute que en inscrivant à ce
dispositif dans la loi ça sera un acte
éminemment positif qui aurait à mon sens
entre sas un aspect terriblement positif
et pédagogique par rapport aux problèmes
majeurs qui subit notre pays c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas véritablement dans
les esprits la culture du don d'organes
c'est cela le véritable problème il ya
des résistants 7
cet amendement encore une fois qui est
largement positif ça serait peut-être de
nature à déclencher une prise de
conscience qui fait défaut dans notre
pays
merci cher collègue madame isabelle
debré pour explication de vote
merci monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
appuyer ce qu'a dit revenir sur ce qu'a
dit marie-thérèse hermange
le groupe ump dans son ensemble est tout
à fait bien sûr monsieur sûr totalement
favorable est complètement favorable au
don d'organes
aujourd'hui toute personne est présumée
consentante sauf avis contraire si on
adopte et ses amendements
ça ne ferait qu'alourdir la procédure
donc il est évident qu'aujourd'hui toute
personne qui n'a pas donné de
dispositions contraires et présumés
consentante pour autant je souhaiterais
soulevé un problème qui m'a quitte à mes
yeux est à vos yeux de beaucoup de nos
collègues et marie thérèse hermange
avait déposé un amendement en ce sens
le problème aujourd'hui c'est aussi
l'accueil des familles lorsque l'on
vient de perdre un être cher
il est extrêmement difficile pour les
familles d'arriver à dire oui pour le
don d'organes quand vous avez un enfant
qui vient de décéder pour le don
d'organes
on manque aujourd'hui cruellement madame
la ministre d'espèces d'accueil pour
accueillir de façon très décente digne
et je dirais extrêmement calme les
familles on le sait les médecins nous
l'ont dit ils nous ont dit que même si
la personne était consentante et même
consentante par écrit on ne va jamais
contre l'avis de la famille
aujourd'hui il est indispensable d'avoir
des aires d'accueil les espaces
d'accueil pour que les familles puissent
faire leur deuil et accepter totalement
le don d'organes on l'a on n'a pas
accepté ne nous avons pas adopter cet
amendement parce qu'il semblerait que
c'est du domaine réglementaire
donc madame la ministre nous vous
demandons je crois que le groupe ump
dans son ensemble nous demande d'aller
voir les hôpitaux et d'inciter les
hôpitaux à créer ces espaces d'accueil
mais encore une fois ci nous a si nous
acceptions c'est ces amendements nous ne
ferions qu'alourdir la procédure c'est
tout ce que je voulais dire et le groupe
ump bien évidemment est tout à fait
favorables au don d'organes lesueur
merci chers collègues monsieur le maine
pour explication vote
le cimt le président moi je crois qu'on
est en plein madame ministre
on est en plein paradoxe tout le monde
est d'accord pour les dons d'organes et
on est en train de se faire de d'initier
une espèce de querelle qui a pas lieu
d'être
tout le monde est d'accord pour les dons
d'organes bien pourquoi refuser des
amendements qui vont valoriser ces dons
d'organes
comment ils vont les valoriser parce que
pour la personne qui veut effectivement
donner un organe
il y a aussi une volonté citoyenne il y
a aussi une volonté en humanité par
rapport aux autres pourquoi pas le
valoriser ça fait quand le tour le fait
de savoir
que son père son grand-père son cousin
veux donner cela s'engage milite et une
attitude militante par rapport au don
d'organes dont on sait dont on a
énormément besoin des hôpitaux puis par
la paix dans ma vie et j'ai bien vu dans
des situations telles que les familles
effectivement en pleine détresse essayé
de se raccrocher à des points durs pour
savoir s'il fallait ou pas nonobstant la
réglementation donc de savoir que la
personne le défunt de son vivant était
militant pour dire je veux faire
connaître en a que citoyen pour aider
les autres à sauver malgré une fois que
ce soit je suis décédé pourquoi essayer
de minimiser cette position-là qui en
plus n'a nulle pas le fait que étant la
présomption de dons d'organes
je dis que là si on va dans le sens de
ces amendements on apporte un plus même
si ces quelques organes en plus on a
besoin de ces organes alors après on se
prive de le dire d'un outil
complémentaire pour faire en sorte que
dans notre pays est beaucoup plus de
dons d'organes qu'il n'y en a
actuellement ce qui est forcément
regrettable et je ne comprends pas c'est
un terme au mans alors que sur le fond
tout le monde est d'accord pour qu'il y
ait des dons d'organes
merci cher collègue monsieur godefroy
pour explication de vote
monsieur le président de l'amith
simplement sur le pont un peu
pragmatique moi je suis très étonné que
l'on se pose la proposition de notre
collègue jean pierre sueur
personnellement personnellement je ne
l'accepterai pas mais je ne m'en rends
pas compte
je n'accepterai pas que les membres de
ma famille puisse douter de ma volonté
mais isabelle debré s'il vous plaît mais
ça peut mais ça peut ça peut arriver et
je pense que je n'apprécierais pas je ne
pourrais pas me rendre compte et donc
moi je pense que c'est une précaution
essentielle
et moi je voudrais rappeler monsieur le
président qu'il me semble que l'an passé
le don d'organes était grande cause
nationale l'an passé où voilà je crois
que l'amendement de notre collègue jean
pierre sueur va justement dans ce sens
il va dans ce sens personnellement moi
j'irai beaucoup plus loin jean pierre ne
m'en voudra pas gelé dit en commission
moi je pense que ce ne serait pas trahir
un secret médical je pense que si
c'était simplement marqué sur la carte
vitale que nous avons tous sur nous que
nous acceptons le don d'organes ça
permettrait de régler le problème très
rapidement alors on me dit c'était une
carte de paiement
si on veut mais je pense qu'on pourrait
l'utiliser autrement on pourrait
l'utiliser autrement et comme ça tout le
monde serait la famille serait que sur
sa carte vitale
chacun a dit je suis favorable mais dans
dans la possibilité de l'esa sur la
carte vitale
il faudra en discuter je crois que je
vois pas pourquoi vous vous opposez à la
proposition de jean pierre sueur
ce n'est qu'à les verts véritablement le
don d'organes volontaire et moi j'aurai
je voudrais dire je souhaite moi ce
qu'elle souhaitait jean pierre sueur
c'est que comme ça j'aurai la certitude
m'inscrivant sur ce registre qu'on ne
reviendra pas sur mes volontés
je n'ai pas de doute sur les mes proches
mais on ne reviendra pas sur mes
volontés
elles seront clairement affichées si
cher collègue monsieur michel pour
explication de vote
merci monsieur le président je pense
qu'on est je ne sais pas où on se trouve
en pleine contradiction
madame debré les aires d'accueil c'était
prévu pour d'autres personnes que pour
les familles donc vous vous laissez
aller à des facilités de langage
ceci dit nous avons tous nous avons tous
assisté à des débats
moi si j'avais su je rapportais le nom
des gens j'aurai retrouvé mes papiers
sur les dons d'organes où il y avait des
médecins qui pratiquent où il y avait
des associations et qui tousse tousse
tousse tousse nous ont dit que c'était
très difficile très difficile et que le
cas lorsque le consentement et
simplement présumés en fait il n'ya pas
de prélèvement pourquoi parce que les
familles sont dans la douleur parce
qu'on leur pose à peine la question et
qu'elle ne réponde pas parce que si
elles répondent leur époque sont
contradictoires entre l'épousé les
enfants par exemple
et dans ce cas là
on ne prélève pas pour ne pas je dirais
ajouter de la douleur à la douleur
voilà donc la solution de dire si on est
d'accord on le dit avant et la question
est réglée une fois pour toutes
et puis ça n'empêche pas que le
consentement restes présumés pour les
autres et que dans ces cas là est bête
peut-être que on arrivera à ce que des
familles sont consentantes pour le don
d'organes
voilà donc je trouve que les arguments
du groupe rpr
n'en déplaise à marie thérèse hermange
sont totalement à côté de la réalité
et pourtant et pourtant elle connaît
bien la réalité les hôpitaux
elle connaît bien la réalité de la
maladie et sur ce plan-là je trouve
ainsi reconnaît que vous êtes avec votre
groupe totalement à côté de la plaque
mais c'est cher collègue monsieur signé
pour explication de vote
présidents ministres à un mot pour dire
que évidemment moi je suis d'accord avec
ce que dit jean bien sûr et je vois pas
comment on pourrait s'y opposer
simplement je pense qu'il est il est
délicate mais difficile et même
impossible de prélever 20 devrait dès
que toute personne qui n'a pas manifesté
de refus de donner ses organes est
susceptible d'être donneur requis quand
même difficile de prélevé un organe sans
l'accord au moins de 6 mai du du malade
lui-même d'accord au - delà de la
famille mais moi mon expérience
d'internât m'avait montré que les les
personnes les donneurs les plus
recherchés sont des jeunes soient
évidemment on va pas prélever leurs
organes
lambert de kavala on n'est pas sûr
qu'ils sont en bon état celui là il a
peut-être manifesté au cours de sa vie
l'intention de laisser à mes yeux rien
n'en veut pas on veut dès organes de
gens qui sont morts mais en général de
morts brutales non prévisibles et qu'ils
eurent eux n'ont jamais pensé parce
qu'ils ont 20 ans à savoir s'il allait
ou non donner leurs organes c'est ça le
problème est donc le dans la
dramatisation qui suit évidemment
l'accident
l'émotion que ce qu'a dit jean pierre
jean pierre michel tout à l'heure dans
cette moment d'émotion qu'elle comment
voulez-vous faire pression sur une
famille déjà a qu'un comme le mans dans
le chagrin est dans la détresse les ars
oi comment aller les interroger au
savoir si on peut prélever un organe ans
et cet organe là qu'on veut justement et
cet organe halde le le malheureux qui
est dans le coma ou tués par hugo bagué
par l'état va répondre je ne peux pas
parler et la famine ne sera pas à
s'exprimer là dessus en c'est justement
cet organe qui pour les médecins et le
plus valable
merci chocolat et monsieur barbier pour
explication de vote
monsieur le président n'est plus
ministre
moi je ne voterai pas ces amendements
parce que nous sommes bien entendus dans
cette position d' essayer de tout faire
pour améliorer le don d'organes mais là
on est dans une discussion tout à fait
théorique seront deux listes une liste
de ceux qui refusent carrément de ne pas
donner une liste de ceux qui seront
inscrits sur une liste qu'il faudra
consulter et va se poser un problème
c'est que de toute façon c'est à la
famille de décider
même si le défunt a exprimé sa volonté
de donner
on ne pourra pas prélever sans
consentement de la febiac
à partir de ce moment là se pose aussi
dans notre problème c'est qu'on peut
être
favorable un don d'organes mais de quels
organes et me signale signaler un dit
maintenant une chose exact on peut être
favorable
un don d'organe de rein de coeur pas
forcément un don d'organe de face ou de
corner et on sait que ou de bar on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la complexité des
prélèvements d'organes fait qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une discussion approfondie
entre le corps médical les équipes qui
sont capable de prélever d'ailleurs
parce que ce n'est pas partout dans tous
les hôpitaux qu'on est capable de parer
un prélèvement je crois qu on complique
une chose on veut instaurer à partir
d'un bon sentiment j'en doute pas à une
possibilité d'un nouveau régis qui va
compliquer les choses et à mon avis même
si on est en retard je pense qu'il faut
plutôt poursuivre l'information il
manque
il manque des organes il manque des
organes d'acorn on peut peut-être
effectué par rapport à d'autres pays on
est en retard par rapport aux besoins
quand même et à partir de ce moment là
je crois que c'est ces amendements
risque de compliquer inutilement les
choses sa collègue mme borvo cohen seat
explications de vote
merci ce président c'est la dernière
intervention qui m'amène à dire quelque
chose parce que derrière c'est
d'ailleurs c'est ça paraissait en
filigrane derrière vos interventions
moi je crois que bien sûr le fait que
l'enregistrement positif de la volonté
d'une personne vivante ne règle pas tout
bien évidemment pas ce que ça peu être
obligatoire mais on peut encourager par
contre les personnes à exprimer
librement
même quand elles sont jeunes ce qu'elle
pense si elle le pense du fait qu'elle
fait qu'elles pensent qu'elles veulent
pouvoir donner leurs organes en cas
d'accidents et de morts subites
mais voyez au travers ce que vous dites
apparaît une chose que là je récuse
complètement parce que ça nous amène sur
autre chose que vous êtes libre de
penser mais je crois que c'est quand
même assez curieux c'est au fond que le
libre arbitre du vivant n'existe pas
puisque ont foncé la famille qui
décidera en tout état de cause mais ça
c'est complètement aberrant
enfin franchement ben oui les saules et
de vous le dire mais voilà alors qu'il
faille parler avec la famille parce que
peut-être la famine ignore-t-elle que la
personne décédée a inscrit sa volonté
positive c'est tout à fait possible les
gens ne raconte pas leur vie mais
peut-être eux-mêmes alors personnes les
plus proches
mais vous avouerez que quand même que
pour l'équipe médicale
c'est plus facile de parler à la famille
en disant mais le voilà le la personne a
laissé son consentement et je vous
assure que quand même la plupart des
familles même si elles sont contre
peuvent admettre qu'on respecte le libre
arbitre d'une personne quand elle était
vivante
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur
je voudrais je voudrais quand même
réparer quelques erreurs de langage
quand on dit en france on est enfin
c'est faux c'est vrai que par rapport
aux besoins
on a des problèmes on n'est pas en
retard par rapport à d'autres pays
monsieur mirassou on est quand même
devant nous il n'y a que l'espagne et le
portugal et l'espagne et portugal
rémunère le don chez nous il est gratuit
savait qu'en espagne par exemple si vous
êtes encore en état de mort cérébrale en
vous prélève avec l'accord de la famille
les reins le coeur enfin tout ce qu'on
peut et sait et l'enterrement est payé
par l'état et non pas par la famille en
france dedans et gratuit
c'est donc pour ça qu'il ya peut-être
plus de dons en espagne que qu'en france
puisque au moins ils n'ont pas payé
enterrement donc c'est un autre problème
mais pour l'instant je termine monsieur
je termine c'est la vérité et fait ce
sont donc pour l'instant est évident que
en france je voulais dit tout à l'heure
espagne portugal 30 dont 20 millions
d'habitants en france 24 dont pour un
million d'habitants
donc on n'est pas en retard les besoins
ne sont pas couverts
mais on n'est pas en retard par rapport
à d'autres pays ça c'est une lycée c'est
une vérité il faut rétablir la vérité il
ya du public elle et les gens se disent
tiens on est en retard alors que ce
n'est pas vrai le deuxième point le
nombre de greffes sur le territoire
national en 2009 nous avons il a été
réalisé par don nous pendant mon âme est
ministre il a été réalisée 4664 greffe
en 2009 sur le territoire national dont
235 sur donneur vivant donc le reste
c'est évidemment sur des donneurs en
état de mort cérébrale ce qui est déjà
pas si mal
enfin d'ailleurs monsieur sûr c'est
vraiment une fausse bonne idée mettre en
place une liste de volontaires qui
veulent donner l'or l'or l'or
leurs organes encadrement cérébrale face
tout en laissant la loi caillavet à côté
ça veut dire que ceux qui intimement
veulent donner leur leur leurs organes
mais ne se sont pas inscrits ne seront
pas inscrits s'il leur arrive malheur de
mourir ce qui veut dire que la famille
ce qu'ils disent oui mais non ce qui
veut dire que la famille qui sera
consulté par les médecins dira non il
est pas inscrit donc il est pas
d'honneur et ça va diminuer
ça va diminuer le nombre de donneurs ça
va diminuer le nombre de dons
c'est une fausse bonne idée donc nous
sommes nous favorables au don nous
sommes favorables à loi est la loi
caillavet
nous sommes favorables à ce que
d'ailleurs il ya des articles qui
suivent sur l'information à donner à
l'ensemble de la population y compris
aux jeunes afin qu'ils puissent affirmer
leur volonté d'être donneur mais nous ne
pouvons pas être favorable à des fausses
bonnes idées
madame la ministre qui va vous parler
après à elle même travaillé dans des
centres de transplantation
elle sera menée en plus compétentes que
moi pour continuer ainsi le rapporteur
madame la barre pour explication de vote
c'est sur l'a89 sais pas quoi madame la
barre sur le 89
on va attendre on est on est sur 88
monsieur retailleau pour l'explication
de vote jugés écoutaient attentivement
les points de vue des uns des autres
parce qu'on dit sur des sujets
extrêmement compliqué mais je ne voterai
pas ces amendements je pense que à terme
les deux régimes ne pourront pas
cohabiter
je pense que juridiquement on va
vraiment mes chers collègues vers des
conflits juridiques importants et que le
système de consentement positif tueur à
un moment ou un autre le système actuel
on ne peut pas être je crois vraiment
sur deux systèmes différents sans
risquer un moment ou à un autre des
conflits juridiques et vous verrez que
la jurisprudence
un moment ou un autre un moment ou un
autre privilégiera un système par
rapport à l'autre je ne crois pas une
seule seconde à ce que à moyen terme il
puisse y avoir la coexistence de deux
régimes aussi distincts je suis pour la
formule de la loi caillavet c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suivrai le
rapporteur je pense que c'est un avis
âge même si moi j'ai entendu les avis
des uns et des autres mais je voulais
apporter cet élément au débat merci j'ai
un collègue madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président simplement
pour dire je rejoins l'avis du
rapporteur c'est à dire que en effet il
ya les difficultés pour recueillir le
consentement du défunt on le sait je je
vienne à d'un service de transplantation
je sais ce que c'est mais en effet la
l'établissement d'un registre de
consentement exprès et une finalement
une fausse bonne idée je le dis tout
comme le rapporteur parce que comme je
le dis aussi tout à l'heure dans les
pays où ce registre de consentement a
été mis en place
il faut une démarche volontaire de la
personne pour aller s'inscrire et
consentir au don
or c'est une démarche qui n'est pas
automatique on nous aurons beaucoup de
mal à avoir le consentement en tout cas
là la vie de nos concitoyens dans cette
démarche est à mon avis la conséquence
qui se produit c'est qu'on aura une
baisse du nombre de dons parce qu'il y
aura une baisse de disponibilité
d'organes et donc parce que les gens
n'iront pas s'inscrire seul et sur ses
listes la question de la coexistence des
deux jce pose aussi une vraie difficulté
d'une part vous voulez que je parlais
que je vous réponde ou pas alors si vous
parlez en même temps que moi vous le
demander au président qu'il revient bon
temps mais
le ministre
mais vous voulez parlez vous le demander
au président vous vous exprimez je
m'exprimerai après y'a aucun problème
alors madame la ministre vous avez la
parole
je redis donc que le consentement exprès
sur un registre particulier aboutirait à
une baisse du don d'organes
il y aura un manque de disponibilité
d'organes parce que la démarche n'est
pas aussi automatique que ça de plus
deux registres qui coexistent crée
évidemment beaucoup de confusion auprès
de nos concitoyens
comment imaginer pour une équipe de
grève qui va vouloir à tout prix avoir
cette information cruciale qui va aller
sera un geste de refus qui ne trouvera
pas le nom de la personne qui rassure un
registre de consentement qui ne
retrouvera pas long à personne comment
pour une équipe qui doit prendre une
décision
comment c'était qui pourra se déterminer
sur la volonté du défunt
nous sommes là dans une impasse totale
qui ne réglera pas le problème
je voudrais aussi rappeler que le
dispositif qui est aujourd'hui en
vigueur en france est un dispositif qui
a été reconnue au niveau de l' oms est
reconnue parce qu'ils constituaient deux
dispositifs qui était le plus par
pertinents je pense parallèlement à cela
que nous avons intérêt à trouver de
nouveaux dispositifs pour motiver
justement le don d'organes et je crois
que dans le cadre de cette loi le fait
d'élargir le don d'organes à des proches
ayant des liens étroits et stables est
une bonne disposition qui permet
effectivement de recourir à davantage de
possibilités pour les personnes en
attente de greffe merci madame le
ministre
alors je vous propose donc de voter sur
le 88 rectifier que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien levé la main
j'en ai courts que ceux qui sont contre
eux veulent bien levé la main il n'est
pas adoptée sur le 156 rectifié même
vote même vote
nous en arrivons à l'amendement 15 j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe socialiste sur cet
amendement numéro 15
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable à vis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront secrétaire un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre métro
un bulletin bleu
ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir
remettront un bulletin rouge le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
m
et
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
la province
m
oh
résultat du scrutin numéro 179 sur
l'amendement numéro 15 stands ont inséré
un article additionnel après l'article 5
oui
de votants 339 nombre de suffrages
exprimés 336 majorité absolue des
suffrages exprimés 169 pour l'adoption
152 contre 184 le sénat n'a pas adopté
nous en arrivons à l'amendement 89
rectifier c'est une demande
d'explications de vote de madame la
barre
j'aurais revenir sur l'amendement 89 que
l'amendement 89 n'est pas pour limiter
le don d'organes au contraire c'est pour
limiter cette possibilité dole de
rechercher à tout prix une opposition
qui aurait été exprimée par un proche
approche ça veut dire quoi jusqu'où on
va donc je relis l'article 1230 2-1
si le médecin n'a pas directement
connaissance de la volonté du défunt
il doit s'efforcer de recueillir auprès
des proches l'opposition au doux
d'organes éventuellement exprimer donc
le mot éventuellement est aussi flou et
le mot proches et icloud ou donc nous
nous proposons de limiter cette
opposition aux parents de la personne
mineure et à la personne de confiance
désignée
si la personne est adulte merci chers
collègues je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe crc spg sur
l'amendement numéro 89 rectifié de
monsieur fisher et les membres du groupe
crc spg je vous rappelle que l'avis de
la commission est défavorable l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront secrétaire un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre mais
trois bulletins bleus ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettront un
bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
ouvert
jouer
nous
et
d
jean
alors
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos j'invite mesdames et messieurs
les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
beaucoup
à
non
m
je ne sais pas
résultat du scrutin numéro 180 sur
l'amendement numéro 89 rectifié tendance
inséré un article additionnel après
l'article 5 nombre de votants 338 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 324 majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés 163 pour
l'adoption 139 contre 185
le sénat n'a pas adopté nous passons à
l'amendement numéro 16 qui est un
amendement de cohérence madame la
ministre
puisque le vote est effectuée je
voudrais m'adresser à la haute assemblée
et dire que le comportement d'un des
vôtres est inacceptable
la manière de déconsidérer un ministre
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions dans le
cadre d'un examen de textes qui traitent
de sujets de société deux sujets majeurs
qui pour moi dépasse tous les clivages
partisans
mais qui nous font réfléchir sur ce que
va devenir notre société eh bien je
trouve inacceptable vos propos monsieur
michel donc je le dis solennellement
j'attends de votre part des excuses
aujourd'hui demain après demain je les
attends libre à vous de prendre acte de
la non pertinence de vos propos et de
m'envoyer vos excuses
monsieur michel pour un rappel la
ministre je prends acte de ce que vous
avez dit si je vous ai blessé
je m'excuse mais je constate mais je
constate les théières en séance de nuit
que vos réponses ne sont pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'on peut attendre du
représentant du gouvernement dans ce
débat et que et que et que la plupart du
temps vous êtes contenté d'être une même
avis que le rapporteur ce n'est pas vous
qu'elle met en cause c'est l'ensemble du
gouvernement bien nous prenons acte des
excuses
nous en arrivons à l'amendement numéro
il est un amendement de cohérence il est
présent il est soutenu pas de demandes
d'explications de vote
alors monsieur rapporteur quel est
l'avis de 105 jours le 6 mai sur le 16
c'est un amendement de cohérence donc
c'est un avis défavorable comme le
président trêve il est favorable mais ma
vie fade demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veuille
bien levé la main l'amendement n'est pas
adopté donc nous en arrivons nous en
arrivons l'article 5bis gingins rappelle
heureusement monsieur michel remercie
monsieur présidence et en dehors d'une
autre débat c'était le rappel règlement
qui se fonde sur l'ensemble notre
règlement en effet le règlement du sénat
ne puis senna ne fait pas de distinction
entre les sénateurs quel que soit le
département dont ils sont élus or dans
moins d'une heure va être rendue pas
loin d'ici
un hommage national à aimé césaire et à
ma connaissance à cet hommage national
seuls ont été invités quelques
parlementaires en dehors des membres de
la conférence du président je me pose la
question
la nation se réduit-elle à eux ce serait
plus grave encore si en dehors des
membres de la conférence des présidents
étaient invités ce qu'il est appelé les
parlementaires ultramarins
ce serait une marque technicisme qui me
paraît intolérable
tous les sénateurs ont les mêmes droits
les mêmes devoirs et tous représentent
la nation
je vous demande donc de prendre à des
rappels au règlement d'en référer au
président et qui devra à mon avis le
transmettre à la puissance invitante
je pense qu'ils allient de l'elysée actu
vous est donné nous en arrivons donc à
l'article 5 bis avec l'amendement 59
rectifier il est présenté par monsieur
barbier
le président le ministre mes chers
collègues l'article 5bis part d'une
bonne intention qui est celle de
l'information la plus large possible sur
le don d'organes le don du sang
cependant il pose un problème dans la
mesure où cette information est délivré
au sein d'établissements scolaires
notamment des listes des lycées à une
population mineurs et que dans le cadre
de cette information
les mineurs seront soumis à une sorte de
pression d'information qui va peut-être
à l'encontre de disposer que ce que
souhaitent les parents et cette
disposition risque d'être à l'origine de
conflits familiaux
sachant que les prélèvements ne sont pas
autorisés sur les mineurs sans
consentement des parents donc cet
amendement vise à propose de limiter
l'information aux élèves majeurs dans
les lycées laissant la possibilité à
l'autorité parentale d'orienter de leur
enfant vers des associations le don
d'organes ou de feu à eux mêmes à la
maison
la promotion de ce don d'organes
je ne pense pas que ceci relève de
l'activité d'enseignement qui doit être
dispensée dans les lycées aux mineurs
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
la vie la commission merci monsieur
brisant la l'article 5 bis comme le
disait gilbert barbier vise à instaurer
une information systématique sur le don
d'organes et le don de sang en direction
des jeunes dans les lycées c'est à dire
donc à partir de la seconde et dans les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
à retirer l'intérêt de cet article 5 bis
est précisément mon cher collègue de
permettre une information avant la
majorité pour que dès que celle-ci venu
le jeune adulte puisse décider s'ils
veulent ou non donné l'information ne
créons pas d'obligation le consentement
parental
ne paraît pas plus nécessaire que pour
toute autre information donnée dans les
lycées la contraception par exemple donc
la commission a donné un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur rapporteur madame le
ministre l'avis du gouvernement avis
défavorable je rejoins les arguments du
rapporteur deux rapporteurs par ailleurs
ce message est plutôt positif et les
jeunes sont plutôt sensible à la
dimension généreuse du don une
sensibilisation précoce à ces questions
est importante au regard des positions
qu'ils prendront à l'âge adulte je crois
que c'est une une bonne préfiguration
des citoyens qui est qu'ils seront
demain le dos constitue aussi une façon
de développer chez les jeunes la
responsabilité citoyenne vis-à-vis de la
société pour ces raisons le gouvernement
est défavorable
merci madame le ministre pour
explication de vote madame hermange une
précision parce que comme dans
ultérieurement en fait il est proposé
une journée nationale sur le don
d'organes et qui est inclue le don de
gamètes
je voulais savoir si
dans l'information qui était de 17
exclusivement don d'organes et de sang
ou si les gamètes sont incluses
très bien
bon en posant la question pardon
monsieur rapporteur malaisie oui le 5
bis dis bien une information dispensée
dans les lycées et établissements
d'enseignement supérieur par l'institut
national de prévention et d'éducation
pour la santé sur la législation
relative au don d'organes à des fins de
greffe et si on met moyen de faire
connaître sa position de son vivant don
d'organes et donc c'est tout by ap à don
de gamètes
merci monsieur leurs deux pôles
explications de vote
moi j'aurais assez volontiers suivi
gilbert barbier sur son amendement
non pas que sur le fond je ne considère
qu'il faille pas donné d'information
simplement je m'interroge pour savoir si
le cadre est bien approprié
j'ai vu une assez longue expérience
d'enseignement en lice et on demande
tellement de choses à faire dans les
lycées et collèges pour la ici ce sont
les lycées il ya une multitude
d'informations que l'information tu
l'information alors si en plus c'est sur
le temps scolaire je vous garantis que
les jeunes étant ce qu'ils sont c'est à
dire pas plus mauvais que nous dans le
passé ils verront une bonne récréation
au point final monsieur masson pour
l'explication de vote
oui pour ma part je partage tout à fait
le point de vue de notre collègue je
pense que il faut arrêter de surcharger
dans les lycées etc
indépendamment de simples je pense que
ce qui va être fait dans les lycées
c'est de l'information mais c'est plutôt
dans de l'information orienté c'est très
certainement pas de l'information avec
le point de vue d'un côté le point de
vue de l'autre et je pense que pour
démineurs je pense que pour démineurs
c'est pas simple de se trouver dit je
dirais soumis à un d'éventuelles
pressions de même que tout à l'heure
j'étais un peu surpris qu'un nos
collègues puissent proposer que le fait
qu'on veuille être devin you ou ne
veuille pas et donneurs plus est inscrit
sur la carte vitale moi je pense que les
gens ils ont quand même le droit aussi
un d'avoir leur jardin secret de d'avoir
leur point de vue de leur côté et on
n'est pas obligé d tous fichés on n'est
pas obligé d'accepter non plus que sont
nos enfants mineurs on est une certaine
je dirais un certain enrôlement dentelle
ou dentelle dans tel ou tel sens il peut
y avoir des parents qui ne souhaitent
pas que leurs enfants mineurs soient
orientés dans telle ou telle direction
et je pense qu'il faut le respecter
quand les enfants sont majeurs
c'est autre chose mais je trouve que cet
amendement est tout à fait pertinent
merci cher collègue madame debré pour
explication de vote
merci monsieur le président madame lise
chers collègues une question et une
explication de vote une question quand
on parle de d'élèves majeur je voudrais
bien sûr vous parlez d'élèves majeur de
18 ans ou la maj la majorité médicale 16
ans 18 ans alors au lycée je veux bien
mais au lycée il n'y a plus beaucoup y
en a encore maintenant bon alors
d'accord d'accord alors en terminale
vous aurez un mélange de 18 tonnes est
en terminale vous aurez un mélange
d'élèves de 18 ans donc majeur et une
autre partie car à 16 ans alors on fait
quoi on prend ce qu'ils sont majeurs on
aimait d'un côté on leur fait
l'information et ceux qui ont saison ils
vont rester dans la classe ça paraît
assez compliqué et à titre là c'est mon
vote personnel je trouve que le don
d'organes est quelque chose de très
noble de très beaux de très pur de très
généreux je pense qu'on peut
sensibiliser les jeunes très tôt en
revanche j'aurais une autre question qui
informera comment seront ils informés
parce que c'est pas neutre la formation
doit être doit être dispensée par des
gens de qualité
ce sera ça ma petite réserve donc je ne
sais pas si m je ne je ne sais pas
madame la ministre si vous pouvez nous
éclairer sur ce sujet qui informera et
me dire que si bien 18 ans merci et cher
collègue madame le texier pour
explication de vote
oui
je voulais dire d'eux deux ou trois
choses premièrement je pense qu'il
s'agit d'une information sur un problème
important sur un problème de société et
qui ne s'agit en aucun cas de faire du
prosélytisme
je pense que ce n'est pas à ce n'est
venu à l'idée de personne d'essayer
pardonner la vulgarité du propos de
racoler des enfants au lycée pour que
demain lorsqu'ils seront majeurs ils
donnent leurs organes il s'agit de les
informer sur quelque chose d'important
et de ne pas faire de prosélitisme
deuxièmement pour avoir une petite
pratiques d'intervention dans les
établissements scolaires les lycéens et
même les collégiens sont extrêmement
intéressé par les problèmes de société
et par les informations que l'on peut
leur donner à ce propos donc voilà
peut-être que peut-être que les
enseignants sont surchargés en vend
c'est pourquoi mais les sciences de la
vie
c'est quelque chose de décent ciel et je
pense que nous avons de bonnes raisons
en tout cas groupe socialiste de voter
contre l'amendement de monsieur barbier
il faut arrêter d'avoir peur de tout
mais c'est cher collègue pas d'autres
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter
pardon madame jeu sans merci
oui mais moi je suis d'accord avec
l'amendement barbier je suis d'accord
avec l'amendement barbier parce que je
pense qu'on fait porter beaucoup de
choses aux enfants que souvent entre
information et prosélytisme
la frontière n'est pas tout à fait net
il me semble que l'âge de 18 ans et
peut-être plus à ne pas être plus à ne
pas les interpeller directement il leur
faut apporter des choses qui ne sont pas
encore de leur âge
merci cher collègue monsieur godefroy
pour explication de vote
oh juste un mot après les propos de
notre collègue sincèrement est-ce que
vous croyez vraiment aujourd'hui que nos
jeunes qui ont 16 17 ans ne se pose pas
tous ces problèmes là sincèrement croyez
vous qu'ils sont complètement en dehors
de ce cas objecté répondez moi vous
croyez que ce sont des questions qui ne
se pose pas bien sûr que s'ils se
déposent il s'en pose bien d'autres à 16
ou 17 ans arrêtez de vouloir beta cocon
en dix ans avant 18 ans il se pose
aucune question ils ont pas ils ont pas
de 2,2 de dérogation quant à
l'organisation de la société
bien sûr que oui long et le 2 montre
souvent et moi je trouve quand on parle
de prosélytisme ou d'embrigadement j'ai
entendu ça et bien finalement moi je
suis contre tout embrigadement par
nature je suis rétif absolument mais
finalement que l'on fasse d'une
information qui va créer des citoyens
bien informés qu'ils sauront qu'ils
pourront donner leurs organes dans
l'avenir pour sauver des vies et bien
moi je trouve que c'est une très bonne
chose mais d'abord vos explications de
vote
merci oui je fais c'est pas une
explication de vote je voudrais faire
une remarque parce que ça fait je crois
qu'il faut la faire et elle ça peut
servir
si vous voulez je constate que les mêmes
parce que bon c'est comme ça on est au
parlement donc on s'exprime d'un côté ou
de l'autre de l'hémicycle qui ne veulent
pas d'information sur la sexualité sur
le sida sur différentes questions de ce
type est maintenant sur le don d'organes
aux jeunes qui ne sont pas majeurs c'est
à dire en gros entre 16 et 18 ans parce
que il ya plus de bages le au lycée ceux
qui ont plus de 18 ans il a très peu un
est par contre sont les mêmes qui
veulent toujours abaisser la majorité
pénale qui veulent les punir le plus tôt
possible qui veulent passer de 16 à 13
ans pour la responsabilité pénale qui
veulent les mettre en prison plutôt
ainsi leur récuse le fait qu'ils sont
encore des enfants à 18 ans alors voyez
voilà ça va servir mon intervention elle
va servir et je vous la ressortirai je
vous promets
monsieur retailleau pour explication de
vote pour dire je suis pas favorable à
cet amendement jeu super de collégiens
et de lycée et je trouve que sur cette
question qui touche vraiment au coeur de
la vie et même aux origines d'ailleurs
du don d'organes je trouve que tout ce
qui peut éveiller la conscience de nos
jeunes quittant parler ensuite en
famille est plutôt quelque chose de
positif
voilà merci monsieur barbier pour
explication de vote
je relève les propos de madame borvo
madame pour vous il faut savoir que tout
en étant mineur on peut contracter le
sida
par contre concernant le don d'organes
malheureusement on ne peut pas on peut
pas ou alors il faut dire que le lit
mineur sont autorisés on peut autoriser
les prélèvements sur les mineurs mais il
ne faut pas comparer des choses parce
que ça n'est pas comparable
autant l'information sur les problèmes
de vih ou de contraception me paraissent
importants encore que de les faire en
milieu scolaire ne paraissent pas la
meilleure façon de les informer parce
que vous pouvez aussi parlé des
problèmes de toxicomanie ou c'est très
bien et c'est démontré que les
informations qui a donné en milieu
scolaire n'est pas celle qui porte le
mieux vis-à-vis des enfants
moi je pense que dans la mesure où le
thon d'organes n'est pas autorisée pour
les mineurs il faut laisser aux familles
jouer un certain rôle n'abandonnons pas
totalement la responsabilité parentale
sur un problème que les mineurs ne
peuvent pas gérer eux mêmes alors ça moi
je pense que effectivement on peut
considérer un tas de choses aussi
extrême que vous le faites madame la
présidente
mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas comparer
ce qui n'est pas comparable chaque
collègue mme tasca pour explication de
vote
le mans pour ajouter un argument aux au
refus de cet amendement je dirais
craintif peureux par rapport à l'état
actuel de la jeunesse je veux souligner
que sur des sujets aussi importants
nos lycéens ne sont pas tous en
situation d'égalité le milieu familial
mais nous le savons ce n'est pas la
peine de le nier
sur toute une série de problèmes ceux de
la sexualité c'est évident on l'a admis
sur les problèmes de la vie et de la
mort les jeunes aujourd'hui ne sont pas
en situation d'égalité dans leur famille
et d'ailleurs quel que soit je dirais
l'origine familiale
donc c'est tout de même une évidence
aujourd'hui que le milieu scolaire peut
au moins en partie compensé ce que
n'apporte pas le milieu familial donc je
pense que nous n'avons pas à être
frileux sur ce domaine d'autant qu'il
s'agit évidemment pas de proposer aux
jeunes mineurs d'être demain des fins
d'être tout de suite des donneurs mais
si la question se pose dans leur
environnement familial par exemple ça
peut arriver
un grand frère qui décèdent par accident
et que la question du don d'organes se
pose est bien mieux vaut qu'il y ait eu
un minimum d'information et de
préparation
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
là je vais non non non non je vais
revenir sur les propos d'alain borvo
parce que je les ai trouvé un petit peu
déplacé dans dans l'âme ou dans la
mesure dans la mesure où non j'ai pas
dis ma le vg10 déplacer dans la mesure
où nous savons et on a contesté dans la
constater dans le cadre des travaux de
la commission des affaires sociales que
chacun des sujets en train des divisions
à l'intérieur même des partis politiques
alors vouloir faire croire que toute
l'ump et contre une information auprès
des jeunes c'est donc dire une contre
vérité
il y à des dessinateurs de chaque groupe
qui sont d'un certain avis pour
certaines choses d'un autre avis pour
certains d'autres choses par exemple je
suis pour la gpa et je sais bien que
chez vous madame borvo et contre la gpr
donc il ya vraiment des différences
importantes et qu'il faudra qu'il faut
clarifier au moins pour le public
si nous on est au courant mme wafa ya
des jeunes qui nous regardent il faut
qu'ils sachent que ce qui a été dit
n'est pas une vérité le premier point
est dit le deuxième point pour répondre
à isabelle debré le l'information sera
donnée par l'institut national de
prévention et d'éducation pour la santé
et puis le dernier point pour les jeunes
la majorité médicale ses 16 ans la
majorité ses 18 ans tout le monde sait
faut savoir que le don d'organes vivants
sur les jeunes est interdite point donc
jusqu'à la majorité de 18 ans et si
malheureusement il leur arrive de
décéder le don d'organes sur des jeunes
décédés de mort cérébrale ne peut être
autorisée que par les parents et
uniquement par les parents cette
information là il faut bien la donner
donc je suis pas du tout favorable à la
vie à l'amendement de gilbert barbier
parce que au moins sept informations sur
la législation c'est dans le texte est
bien marqué l'information sur la
gestation du nombre d'organes faut bien
les donner aux jeunes ça me semble être
une évidence
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance à
suivre preuve par 3 l'émission politique
de la rédaction de public sénat
avec ce soir comme invité gérard larcher
président du sénat
bonne soirée à tous
non